oh we're you know what we are getting to
know each other but the dword no why you
what are you scared of buddy I'm not
scared you are you're scared of
something Buddy well I really well I am
scared of all of this lingo and what it
all means and like when when are you
dating someone when are you just [__]
someone like what is it all like I mean
listen why is this uncomfortable Angela
you and I let's say you and I were're
dating what what does that
mean or not exclusive mean what does
that mean I said to you listen you know
I know what you do for work and I want
you to work okay I'm not there's not I
I'm I'm fully supportive of what you do
and I I think it's an art I really do
you're performing it's great okay but I
don't want you to see side dick anymore
outside of work okay so you and I are
exclusive okay right because in the
mornings I want to rub your little head
right kiss you on the forehead and go
good morning I made you breakfast oh I
made you a Denver omelette what's in the
Denver omelet yeah what's in it eggs
let's go baby one [__] yeah man that's
it baby ham right green bell peppers
onions yum yum some
Tomatoes who knows variations variations
anyway I'm going to make you one of
those okay mine that's adorable right
yeah and freshly screened orange juice
wow it's a fres
squee fresy squeeze right okay that
sounds adorable you know what after you
eat your omelette we're going to cuddle
for like an hour oh right and then we're
going to plan the day okay I have a day
planned when are we working what do you
mean no what do you mean you want to
work do do you have a job I wonder oh
you're yourself I'm who no we're not
fictional
character so you've woken up at at at 2:
p.m. she wakes up at 7:00 we learn
listen in this scenario how are we going
to work if you're waking up at 2: p.m.
got real
we can't sleep in the same bed because
I'm if you're coming home at like 5:00
a.m. and getting into bed and waking me
up when I'm waking up in 2 hours I'm
going to be pissed so we're going to
live in separate rooms oh my God it's so
stupid listen to me when are we [__]
how are we going to schedule [__] how
we Fu F [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
everything's about [__] all right not
about [__] all the
time listen okay I'm trying to be this
relationship is hard so hard already
fake relationship already so [__]
hard already so [__] you get up at 7:
and then you go to work yeah so you're
not even there wait wait porn shoots are
at 7:00 in the morning it's usually 9:00
a.m. so I call time is 9:00 a.m.
normally it's pretty standard that's
insane so I've got to be up at 7:00 a.m.
so I can shower and shave and like how
many days a week do you work it depends
but give me average okay but here's I
work every day but I don't shoot every
day oh you write is that what you're
saying no like writing scripts and stuff
I mean no I do like pre and post
production so I do like like editing the
editing schedule actually don't do a lot
of my own editing anymore but I used to
so yeah it's all like music no I well I
pick the music I don't create the music
I'm planning shoot so I'm contacting
other performers for collaboration
talking to my agent about my brow in
sound
effects like no no
like like what about like this an Ari
Aster kind of like oh like an evil grown
oh you want to score like score like Z
[Music]
Vibe like the arrival yeah it was
arrival you I mean like a cool kind of
like a different vibe yeah anyway wait a
second down to produce that with you
already step one is not happening which
is cooking her at Denver omelette cuz
you're not up at 700 a.m. yeah I'm I've
left and you're still sleeping I will
change how this is your I understand you
can't you have to
like you can't you can't because you
have to be you're doing sets at like 10
p.m. right not every night so there's
some nights like Sundays mon I would if
we were da I'll be real okay if I was
dating you right I would I would give
stuff up what would you give up so
Sunday Mondays and Tuesdays are like my
nights not to do stand up okay all right
but then if you're already used to
waking up at two you're still your
body's going to want to wake up at 2 so
we're not so this is what I would do I
know that my sweet lovely um Bumblebee
Angela right a little sweet sweet sweet
pie right a little big titty bubblebee
right I don't know how she flies around
you handle big titty bubble bees yeah
right so I know that my little sweet
sweet dumpling dumpling right is is
going to get up at 700 so what I would
do but she works she has to edit at
10:00 yeah right and she has to do post-
production whatever right so what I
would do is I I'm going to wake up at
600 or not even sleep I won't even sleep
I'll chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop right onions yeah get eggs
right already right I I'll keep peeking
in the room oh sh my little bumblebee
big titty bumblebee is still sleep right
and I would what am I doing
here Peppers no salt orange juice oh
squish s squish what you [__] never
to M School you put
more do a pepper no I'm [__] making a
freshy scree orange juice right orange
juice right you wake up your little
beady eyes right not they're they're
bigger than mine but um yeah what the
[__]
man you have great Eyes by you have
great Eyes by the way yeah yeah I know
why I said that you have little beady
eyes right and and I bring one of those
tray things right oh hone Bunny bref and
bed we eat right maybe we'll watch
whatever you want Bachelor whatever you
want what do you watch by the way oh I
don't really watch anything you guys are
watch so much could you actually um [__]
me instead like could you wake me up
with sex like instead of you don't have
to do all the breakfast you're already
working right yeah it's not the same
though cuz I want to [__] my
bumblebee okay my big bumblebee we [__]
I know but I woke up at 5:30 chopping
[__] down right so it's
like ready yeah get don't cook it just
get it ready to cook in wake me up with
the dick with the dick and then like I'm
like Bliss out you roll out and then
like finish yeah the cook I have to wait
first wait to see if you're fully awake
cuz I want to jam it in when you're
sleeping no like well that's weird if
I've already given you consent for yeah
and don't jam it in you know like wake
me up with little tickles and like
kisses like your hard dick like pressing
up against my thigh and then you like
that yeah yeah so my hard dick is
against your thigh yeah so what's so
funny you say you're just not an
initiator I'm not ever there's no
tickling or pressing up or none of that
yeah like if you don't initiate he will
never oh yeah oh
what I'm just being mindful about a
woman's right yeah but
but hey yeah dude right women's rights
but but if I've said if I'm in this
relationship with you and I've said like
I give you consent to [__] me whenever
like just know I'm ready okay I'm asleep
[__] all right so I'm on the side yeah
and I'm I'm my little dicks hard and I'm
like rubbing against your you're buzzing
too yeah cuz my bubble right I love it
dude I love maybe I'll get the wings
wings every time [__] you put Wings on
and like you know a stripe black and
yellow chopping with the wings on
right right I'm in right I'm rubbing my
right and I stick it in condom or well
we're together right no condom yeah no
condom yeah yeah yeah so we've we've
done all the testing each other so I'm
sing right you know I I already told you
earlier that I can't come I don't know
what happened I can get errected and I
can have sex for hours I just can't come
that's kind of Ideal so yeah is it
really that's what I thought yo that is
ideal huh I'm
back um I've been um releasing myself
theatrically
wow buzz buzz so you can't come don't
say that do you get close do you get
close to coming no no I don't even get
close but I stay miraculously it's full
of pleasure still it feels great yeah I
just so it's you're now you experience
what it's like being a woman
yes yeah yeah it's hard just constantly
[__] and not coming yeah yeah and I
could go for but everyone I'm like oh
what are my cats are doing you or
whatever wait but when you jerk off
you're still coming no you're not either
it's hard it's like it takes hour is
there an orgasm
barely yeah I I don't know there's a
problem go cold turkey nothing for a
month no I would see I'd see my mind I
see a doctor for what for not
coming it could be
like Angela what Angela I'd get your
like hormones checked I'd check like if
there's any like medication vitamins
that you're taking that couldn't have
been couldn't have been C can it be that
I'm 52 true yeah your hormones too young
right and I'm a little too old no it's
too young to not be coming it's to if I
wasn't getting wrecked I'd be I go to
the doctor I get w i b pills I can
easily get acked but do you want to come
not really no oh okay what do we well if
you don't is that in your mind you're
thinking I don't really want to come let
me think buzz buzz
buzzz uh I don't know I think the
pressure of like why aren't I coming uh
oh I'm not going to come and that those
thoughts go myal maybe it's mental yeah
yeah yeah but anyway that's not a bad
thing you know what happened with me
when I started doing spin classes a lot
is I started to lose sensation in my
[__] because of having to sit on that
saddle every single day so it kind of
numbed it out so I had to I have to
hover my [__] over the saddle now and
not sit on the bike so that I don't